こんにちははじめ社長です j 6の世界も相当し信奉しておりまして今や普通にある
ゲームを遊ぶだけではなく自らゲームを作るということもできるんですよねそんな中
あの物件をなんとなくスイッチャー触ってたら
えっそれを自分でやってしまうみたいな方がいらっしゃいました
こちらの方ですどうぞ
ブーバーンヌー
3-5てんですけどいろんなものがあるんで創設ものはやばいですね作ってみたら面白
そうだなっていうのもあったのー
ていましたありがとうございますなんかを群そのツイッターでちょっと見かけたんです
けどもめちゃくちゃ家の間取りがしっかりしてるゲームが目立っ一さんの動画を
めちゃくちゃ三もうた言うの
何かけるなんで存在してるかとか全部入れずと今度は実際にぼくんちに来ていただいた
んですけどもうどうですかいう見て言う
結構被った通りびっくりしたと早速
開発3枚でわかるんだけど
子連れであります鳥端ゲーム
やませていただいていいですかはいじゃあさっそく遊ばせていただきます
はっ
きました8ゲームですもう周りに見たことはがおっとっと右下かも怪しい動きをして
いる
すごいですねー
すごい操作説明メニューを開くがオプション bgm を記しません
地下で調べるなるで会は3角でストレス解消
茉莉ちゃん ok ですなんだか菓子
えっまだりやま俺は水五訓に海辺シェアできた
あっあーやん罰部屋の作り
めっちゃリアですよこれこれや僕ということで
はい
美男ですねあこれ歩けると
ですやまもってすごい本当に
上もうこれ全部剃っこいつよマジでえっもうこれなんか野菜金取ってる上京して俺
we are これすごいいっすよ水たまさんこれ
ありがとうございますやばい必要ところと生きてます
アース五月いやいよいよ様はやばいやばいやばい
馬革車これはで五郎でもバカせる動画ですねそうだか作品なんかすごい
愛を感じますか所沢動かないからこっちの道使えないな
まさにその通りなんですよねやすいゲームをちゃんと置いてあるビューまで
めちゃくちゃ
しっかり作りこまれてますねいやすごー
三角をしたら何かなるかという
ああ
あエンディングだった
ハッハッアッーこれをゲームがあってくだ荘
ああ
バーなるほどですねああ
これで終わっちゃったぞエンディングが10種類あるんですね
よちょっと冒険頑張ります
参加押さない方がいいなこれはちょっとここらへんはもう見たんで
レアですよすごいぞまず作りどれくらいかかったんですかこれ
400時間ぐらい
これがもう流行ってる時間が大切です
合わせこっちできる上水これ俺のかーちゃんが書いてくれなんて冴える鍵ここ
ナックスなんかがバロー cars 中でみましょうね俺が鍵なくしすぎて
これは
明けれる
[音楽]
うわすげぇ普通の玄関だこれ
うわぁわぁわあすごい菅谷 banana cafe これマジで家だこれ
[音楽]
あまってでしょ
あああああ
爆発マン7
まだ2回にはいけないあだろう何が大祭なんかあるんですねいこーなー
何かヒントがあるってことですか
ソウル謎解きみたいな感じで結構そうですね
いや気を付ければほぼ行くとまた爆発するぞ
遠い日入りますあります
おおすごいすごいすごいすごいすごい場面機がそうだったこのトイレには何時代に何
大半作ったんだ
yeah
あれか
関越伝統が可愛させまくって明るくなっただけなんだ
うんごはん大臣ですよあ下田下田下田
しゃしゃん誓ううち日間があるんだったすっかり薄れてだ
うわぁ大すごい地下が本当に
これまたちょっと数内容美術巨
なんだこれ
[音楽]
この ad 始めた瞬間日野聡
筋肉の入学する使用しますか気使ってみまっ
[音楽]
いいか筋肉のはこっち
もう一緒に出来てるんだ
だからお前にはからけどクイズに答えながら9 o 湖西られた得られなかった混ぜ
書いたりしたら
お前は2ついいな ok
えっ
正しい名称なれるこれはう
えっと損ですこれ
あれホネホネザルで作ってですよねそうメッツ深島まで見てますねー
青函よ書士
党是でおねね俺俺俺で俺を出てこれる
売ってもよい
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ではよい多分やばいわかんないし
[音楽]
ああ
バー
取得がはそれは2つ負けですねこれはあれでも正解するとまた進めるって事ですかそう
ですね
ちょっと頑張ろう最後で終わってるんで多分 bs なん
なるほどそんなレディ俺俺俺で俺を売れるでオレオレで俺よ
ちょっと汗名所ん
[音楽]
まあこれはアルティメットどれ零式つけて気がすドライヤーたくさん使ったやつですよ
ね動画で
覚えてる覚えてる覚えてるえっ誰も降らずだよ
ファイルとネイバーや行きぞう蕎麦それしたらいいな
うんよる覚えての金
これが一瞬でせめての髪の毛を乾かす最強のマシーン
爆撃パイルドライヤーです
はい
ん
でもボックスちゃった断崖マップたて誰の俺
獅子だっ
よっしゃー
んいけたこれまでですよ
[音楽]
あ俺がめっちゃ叫んどる
味細胞を進化するんじゃねこれ
[音楽]
f
えっ
腹筋が割れた
とメイクもるっていう熱芸発射できるである2 day
[音楽]
ほんとが出ますね
確かに言われていられますねこれで9ぜっ
まあこっちでも出ますねこれすごい本当に
排水溝に詰まった経緯になりません
ドラゴンのはしごをかけてくれ助かったドラゴン施工かけてるんですか
顔に合っていない
もっと永遠の2実にさんへ
すごいですか小顔何もなさそうな気がするんで
ボールを発射できるだけどでかいんね
これをどう使うすかすねないんですよね得るセーブしたいです
チューブはないですないんですかいやー絶対見せたくないん
とビッグボールもってして
これ b
なんとかしてとビックフォールであっはい
おーやっとは別れてきたと言ったように彼にないように針台が意外にすっごい恋来
てっっ
濃い濃い濃い濃い濃い濃い濃い濃い濃い
廟会結いペットピット強い
をどうしますよねてってっ
ではドクションっていくんですね
バッ
[音楽]
うっうードゥこんにちは
和美社長ですと組まざる立つ税襲われた肇社長
なんでお前ば玄関の前に立っているんだ行く手を阻むな
でも二城田のところじゃあもう意味がわかんないわ昔一緒に動画とっていたえーるあの
信子
なぜ今さら始まる前にどういう歓迎君たち私には分からない
そしてあー誰ステージ2回果たして初めは編集部やに入れるのか
おっと道
頑張らせるこれはどうの開け閉めを何回かやってガードを破壊しなきゃ次にはいけない
のだ
次回なんで俺の部屋の間取りを全部知ってんのお楽しみに